[Musique]
vingt ans c'est l'âge de la jeunesse et
déjà 5 millions de spectateurs 20 ans
ces jeunes et ces vieux l'aventuré a
commencé en 1977 ou en l'an mil on ne
sait plus l'an mil qui du reste est le
nouveau spectacle de cet homme
l'histoire du puy du fou a été une à une
aventure depuis 1978
le puy du fou était méconnu il est
maintenant reconnue et en même temps il
est en plein développement tournée vers
l'avenir en 1900 sont 18 c'était un pari
fou avec un scénario de philippe de
villiers
une population qui s'est progressivement
enrôlé dans le cadre de ce scénario
et puis un succès inouï dès la première
année qui ne s'est jamais démenti depuis
la première du spectacle est un succès
la suite c'est la progression chaque
année des spectateurs cette année sans
doute sept cent mille visiteurs au grand
parcours 350 mille spectateurs à la
cinéscénie et une croissance qui devrait
avoisiner les 25% le tas de broussailles
d'il y a 20 ans est devenue un parc
ultra moderne sans perdre de son
authenticité mais qui finance
bien entendu le puy du fou vit
uniquement de la fréquentation du
million de personnes qui y viennent
chaque année c'est maintenant plus de
110 millions de chiffre d'affaires 600
emplois pendant l'été et puis un bassin
autour de du puy du fou de l'ordre de
1500 personnes puisque nous faisons
travailler essentiellement les personnes
autour du puy du fou lors du fort de
l'an mil à la cité médiévale jusqu'au
castel du puy du fou
c'est d'un château l'autre que
s'envolent depuis 20 ans cette ferry
pour une autre fois
[Musique]